So in our last lesson,
we were learning
all about REST services.
And I suppose in theory now, you
have enough information to
write your own REST library.
You could probably figure out,
in your language, how to make
a call over HTTP.
You could remember to take your
access token and append
it on to any call that--
you know, and you can use your
JSON parser to get back that
data and do fun things
with it.
But generally speaking,
you shouldn't do that.
Just about every major language
out there has a
library to deal with
interacting with REST services.
And they, in general, have dealt
with all the difficult
corner cases that you probably
haven't dealt with yet.
What happens if the
network goes down?
Or what happens if
the token is no
longer valid or is expired?
How can we make sure
we trap that
information instead of crashing?
So you should definitely
use these libraries.
And typically, they come
in three types.
The first type of library
basically abstracts out all
the networking bits.
You still have to have a pretty
good understanding of
the REST calls you're
going to make.
This is an example from the
PHP client library, where
we're just using the Google HTTP
request method to take
care of some of the networking
details.
But you'll notice I still have
to supply the full address of
the endpoint that we want.
I have to specify that
this is a post call.
And I have to supply
the values to this
post call in an array.
What this library does for me
is it remembers the OAuth to
bearer token that I
passed to it in an
initialization step somewhere.
And then it just deals with
making the call, getting the
response, and returning it back
in this bottom line here.
So pretty low level.
Still close to the metal.
The second type of library takes
advantage of something
that Google does, and maybe
other companies as well.
Which is we create this thing
called a discovery document,
which is a very, very detailed
description of everything that
goes on in our REST service.
We have various tools that
analyze our REST service,
produce these very detailed
discovery documents.
And then within each of
our languages, we have
corresponding tools that read in
this discovery document and
essentially convert that into
native objects and calls that
can be made within
that language.
This sounds confusing and
abstract, so let's just show
you an example.
This is the exact same
call that I made on
the previous slide.
The big difference is this PHP
library has a Google game
service .PHP file that
is generated by
one of these tools.
It's analyzed our
REST service.
It's realized that I have a
score slash submit call that
is a post that takes two
values-- the leaderboard ID
and the score value--
and basically turns
that into a method
that I can call directly.
So I'm basically accessing
this variable called game
service, which is a Google Game
Service object, that then
allows me to submit a score to
leaderboard just by calling a
couple of public
methods on it.
I don't have to know that this
is a post call, although I can
probably guess.
And thanks to the magic of
code hinting, my ID can
probably tell me what values
I should be supplying here.
I don't need to look it up in
the REST call or the reference
documentation and look up what
the actual key is for each of
these values, or anything
like that.
It's nicely integrated.
And then the third type of
library is the "Hey, let's
completely abstract this stuff
out for you." And this is what
the Play Games library
for iOS does.
So here I'm creating a score
object by calling the GPGScore
class method score with
leaderboard ID.
I'm assigning it a value.
And then I'm telling
the score value,
hey, go submit yourself.
And here's the completion
handler that you can call when
you're all done submitting
yourself.
And in this completion handler,
I'll have some
information about the score I
submitted, as well as any
errors that need
to be surfaced.
And so you'll notice here,
unlike the PHP library, I'm
not even kicking off
a network call.
I'm passing it onto the library
to say hey, start this
up at an appropriate moment.
And so what the library does is
first, it takes these tasks
that you want to perform and
converts it into the
appropriate REST calls.
It also deals with all the
networking auth junk for me.
At some point, I had to
initialize this with my GPP
sign-in object.
And you'll see that coming up.
But at that point, the library
takes care of managing my
access token for me.
I don't have to actually
know my users' access
token at any point.
It does some smart things, like
intelligently cache data
for me and deal with situations,
for instance,
where I'm offline.
In this case, actually, I can
still submit a score with
completion handler.
And if the user is offline,
the library will be smart
enough to hold onto that score
and wait until I come back
online again.
And then I will attempt to
submit the score in the
background.
What's even better is, by the
way, if I submit a better
score with the same leaderboard
ID, the library
will be smart enough to
disregard this first score and
just use the second one once
I come back online.
So there's a lot of extra
logic that this library
handles behind the scenes for me
when it takes all this and
converts it to REST calls,
which is great.
Except that it doesn't
really do that.
And I guess this
is the big lie.
I've been talking all
about REST services.
It turns out that right now, the
Objective C client library
uses a completely different
service called JSON-RPC.
And JSON-RPC is another set of
rules that can be used to talk
to back-end services.
In some ways it's
similar to REST.
In some ways it's different.
I think one of the biggest
advantages of JSON-RPC is that
it's a little simpler to make
batch calls all at once.
On the other hand, I think
with REST, it's easier to
cache data you get back
from a get call, and
that sort of thing.
And if you're wondering
hey, wait a minute.
Why did you just spent the last
10 minutes teaching me
about REST when the
client library
does something different?
The answer is that I would
actually like you to forget
this technicality and pretend
that the Play Games library
for iOS is also using REST
behind the scenes.
And there's a couple
reasons for it.
Number one, just about every
other client library
already uses REST.
So Android, all of the server
libraries, Java,
PHP, Python, Ruby.
And I'm pretty sure at some
unspecified point in the
future, we'll actually be
changing things on the back
end so that even the Objective
C library is using REST
instead of JSON-RPC.
And frankly, this change
should be completely
transparent to you if using
these libraries, which you
should be for all the reasons
we just went over.
So for the sake of keeping
things simple, let's just
pretend that the Play Games
library for iOS also uses REST
in the back end.
And if somebody wants to tell
you otherwise, it's like that
guy who tells you, hey, peanuts
aren't really nuts.
They're actually legumes.
You know what?
Shut up.
They're nuts.
Nobody cares.
And the Objective C library,
it uses REST
as far as I'm concerned.
So now that we have a better
handle on the Games library
and what it does underneath the
hood, let's actually add
it to our project.
And we're going to do that
in the next lesson.